citizens of the reject Nation we are
back with a very special koi's Comet
Corner catch up on commercials Edition
it's hard to make all those C's just
line up but it does here I am very
excited to watch all of these trailers
because I didn't watch a single one of
them while I was out of town I was
hosting all sorts of insane panels at
Megacon I sat down with Daredevil and
Kingpin themselves me and Charlie Cox
and Vincent afro had a great
conversation I'm gonna fill you in in a
future episode lots of great stuff went
down there for the great the one and
only Carl Weathers teamed up with James
mcavoided tall sword to X-Men goodness
it was it was insane and most of all my
favorite part was I met so many members
of reject Nation I saw more real reject
shirts than I have ever seen in the wild
and so many of you lovelies came up to
say hello so that meant I didn't have
time to watch these trailers because I
don't want to watch them on my phone and
I wanted to share my experience of
watching them with you so I have Scout's
Honor not watched a single one of these
trailers yet and now I'm gonna do them
live we're gonna start with secret
Invasion we're gonna go right into Blue
Beetle and then right from Blue Beetle
into the across the spider-verse trailer
and know how much I love you because I
didn't watch it across the spider-verse
trailer without you that was no easy
feat all I know is there's a Scarlet
Spider frame because dozens of you sent
me that frame that's the most I know of
the trailer please let me know in the
comments which one of these trailers was
your favorite please let me know in the
comments if you were at Megacon and saw
one of my panels because again I met so
many of you I want to see who your names
are in the chat and please let me know
what you want next from this here comic
Corner we are going into spring which
means we are going into summer which
means it is superhero season so let me
know what you want to see from this very
corner without further Ado let's get
into the secret Invasion trailer
[Music]
sure
Since You've Been Gone
still has the eye patch at this point
much worse oh no iPad
oh you think I came back
[Music]
this tone reminds me so much of Winter
Soldier which is exactly what I want I
need grounded for this fight that lies
before us old friend
hahaha
this is personal
very few of us know about the walls
fought in the shadows that have raged on
this planet
do you feel responsible
it's that big scroll shot was new from
the d23 footage where are the Avengers
this war is one I have to fight alone
you're the most wanted man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned
for you
the Great Neck Fury
one last fight
yes
oh June 21st is so close yet so far okay
secret invasion is one of my favorite
runs in the comics because of its
Simplicity where it has an insane
storyline I actually think the modern
secret Invasion comic that just
concluded like a month ago I liked even
more than the original but the fun of
the original comic is that it's one of
those whodunits that can affect everyone
and infect paranoia and everyone we had
Jessica Drew be revealed as a scroll and
that had ramifications for you know 10
years prior and five years forward
there's a lot of big ramifications that
can happen with a a story of basically
like conspiracy to this scale I really
liked the whole trailer feels like an
Espionage Thriller I mentioned Winter
Soldier during it but all of it feels
like that heightened reality paranoia
and there's a lot of really fun details
like the faces of freedom is the label
in front of all the presidents as we see
the new guy we get turn into a bunch of
multiple Scrolls we also get a big shot
that we did not have d23 of these
glowing chess pieces of all these
Scrolls laid it out now I think it was
very publicly revealed that Emilia
Clarke plays a very specific role that
ties into the newer comic book series
very curious how that relates directly
to Nick Fury because it looks like Nick
Fury is using a mausoleum as a satellite
I'm assuming that's a safe house I'm
assuming that's a place he's hidden out
he says it's personal while looking at
his own grave so there's a lot of
backstory here with the skrulls and I
really like that the scrolls look better
to me than they did in Captain Marvel I
don't know if that's budget I don't know
if that's evolution of tech I don't know
if that's just because they're darker
and grittier but that Ben Mendelson
transformation plus when you see that
one girl screaming look excellent and
that's on a TV budget so I think that
the best way to improve where Marvel is
right now is to have a bigger dichotomy
between the cosmic and the grounded this
looks very gritty very grounded even the
Marvel logo looked like it had splatter
on it whether that's steam or blood or
whatnot there's a grit to it that I
think is the right move and this trailer
along with what we saw d23 this is about
half d23 half new footage is exactly
what I think Marvel needs to be doing so
if you're gonna go down to two movies a
year and two show a year this is
absolutely what half of them should be
keep Marvel on the ground as well as in
the sky I'm so over ready for secret
Invasion all right now on to Blue Beetle
this is the first footage I have seen
whatsoever I've only seen the suit so
I'm ready to see what the tone what the
flavor what the feel what the Blue
Beetle is let's get into it
me Mr Reyes
he finished scraping the gum off that
lounge or what
man I can't wait to see sholo kill
enough I feel so out of reach you always
land on your feet bro you're hymen
[Music]
guys but do not open it you went in to
get us jobs and all you brought back was
the hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked
how is that
good
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
that's smart to distinguish from the
Symbiote like that that's cool
[Music]
oh it's like super like MacGyver
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh my space free entry systems ready
what is going on
it's called the scarabs it's some kind
of world destroying weapons it's
designed to protect the toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it doesn't
[Music]
I I think I cut a bus in half the slow
Bow hand touch nice touch
but it belongs to me
no you feel for your family
[Music]
the universe is sent you a gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
ah cool
haha yeah
yeah nice choice
a final fantasy sword that's the move
[Music]
it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
yes and comic books reference okay so we
got Infinity Omnibus Blue Beetle
graduation day and the original Jamie
Reyes stuff that makes a lot of sense
okay let's talk about the Blue Beetle
trailer I'm gonna get right into it this
is the fun I wanted now Show Low looks
absolutely perfect as Reyes I honestly
think as far as casting choices go this
is the Smart blend of bringing in a
young audience because he's one of the
stars of this next generation and he's
got the martial arts background I I
honestly think a lot of him is going to
be in that suit plus the physicality
even if it's not the stunt work just
moving around in a suit you want someone
that knows their z-axis their use of
space their awareness of space when
you've got a practical super suit that
suit looks just as good as it did in
those teased images as it did in those
leaked images I've been waiting to see
it in motion and it reminded me a lot of
The Giver there was this 80s 90s movie
that was the Guyver I think it was Mark
Hamill and that is a high compliment
because practical suits work or they
don't and this looks like one of those
practical suits that absolutely works
and you augment with CGI just like
Jurassic Park all those years ago the
reason Jurassic Parks holds up is that
you've got practical dinosaurs augmented
with CGI versus just purely CGI the
weight is different when there's a
physical body in place then you add to
that the family element which totally
ties into the comic book story lines you
add to that the playfulness of someone
learning their origin story learning to
use these Powers they go along it feels
very much like and and don't get mad at
me for comparing the two but phase one
Marvel when you've got a new world being
introduced so we think this is going to
be the first of the DCU kind of rollover
rolling reboot so some characters can
stay some characters will be rebooted
some characters will be brand new that
might tie in this looks like it could be
beautifully independent of everything
else that would allow for it to be part
of the DCU and I really like the feel of
an origin story with him I also really
enjoy the imagery that going out into
space the cutting the bus in half all of
that feels very much like a comic book
origin story but my only concern is this
looks fun and everyone has lately been
using that as like a swear word when a
movie is fun people like disavow it I
think this is what we want from
superhero movies the sense of play the
sense of wonder the Scarab itself I
didn't realize that Susan Sarandon was
the big bad that is a really fun
playfulness that she can bring a
Darkness to this role you know she's an
older actress that's got a lot of
Gravitas versus a younger actor that has
all this gravitas I really like what
they can do with the dichotomy between
like evil CEO that wants it for profit
versus kid who accidentally was chosen
by the Scarab in the comics the Scarab
is very much like a symbiote it wields
control a lot of times it takes over a
lot of times and it certainly looks like
that's the case here add to that a giant
Final Fantasy sword the playfulness of
what he would do with those Powers this
looks like it captures the fun of Blue
Beetle in a wonderful way and I'd love
to see it's a different Blue Beetle in
the comic books but this playfulness
with Booster Gold in the comics it's the
first Blue Beetle he's the third but I
think this tone could work with Booster
Gold if they decide to go that way with
the Booster Gold show okay hold on
Greg's interrupting me he's in the room
he's right here yes
last frame okay checking the tape
okay oh
oh we've got all three of the blue
beetles okay so this is exciting okay I
I just mentioned he's the third Blue
Beetle the middle Blue Beetle is who I'm
talking about teaming up with Booster
Gold The Duality so this implies to me
that those have already existed and
maybe I'll get my dream and I'll have a
Booster Gold set in the 80s because it'd
be a lot of fun if the future he travels
back from is our near future but if he
goes back to the 80s wherein he could
team up with this original Blue Beetle
and then this being the modern like
today Blue Beetle that is that is yes
I'm glad I'm glad you made me rewind now
that's my head Cannon and if it's not
the case I'll be mad because now I'm a
nerd on the internet I would like that
to happen all right it is time and when
I say it has been a difficult 48 hours
to not watch this when I say that this
is my most anticipated movie of the year
after the first one changed my life I am
so elated to dive into across the spider
verse let's do it
thank you
the animation in the in the teas my name
is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's one and
only Spiderman and things are going
great
all right whatever whatever
so are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish
I
am lying to you and I think you know it
miles
wanna get out of here oh when
oh wait a minute love them already
bug this is unbelievable this is the
lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing was his
idea what's it I gotta do to join this
spider team you can you can never be
part of this don't even get me started
on Doctor Strange and a little nerd back
on Earth 1999
go easy on the kid he had a terrible
teacher Peter smiles
all over
I'll take it Oscar Isaac referencing a
University's in his Moon night is
wonderful
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saved in every world
I want our spot looks like he plays into
the plot I can't do that I can do both
Spider-Man always always
not for Uncle Ben most of us wouldn't be
here
one more
friends
there's no idea what you're doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
do my own thing
[Music]
stop Spiderman
and I looked at my uncle and let me
guess he died
wow
that was so much okay so that might be
the greatest trailer I've ever seen I am
so emotionally invested so immediately
it does so much it doesn't reveal too
much while giving you a lot of teases it
clearly deals with loss Spider-Man and
being Spider-Man as a sacrifice it looks
like Miguel O'Hare has had to sacrifice
everything in something that
specifically miles does costs miguelo
era everything I'm very curious what
that is because it also looks like
Miguel has accepted that whereas miles
has to accept that maybe he loses his
mom or he loses his dad to save everyone
and he opts not to make that choice it
sounds like to me he tries to do both
whether he succeeds or not is going to
be curious because this is across the
spider verse right there's a third film
I would bet the end of this film is a
cliffhanger between whether or not he
succeeds at doing both if the entire
universe and if you look at the end
there's a thing that says text blah blah
to join the spider Society love that
curious but that doing that right after
this but whether or not he chooses to
save the every one of the spider Society
the world or the mother or father he may
lose I assume it's his mom because that
shot of uh his dad falling feels like a
bait and switch it feels too obvious so
I'm guessing his mom but what's
interesting is in the comics he's lost
both of them they've both also come back
what they've done in the comics is the
Ultimate Universe kind of imploded
there's a big incursion event but when
it got reset there is an element that uh
without giving too much away he's able
to do something that brings both of his
parents back both of his parents are
alive in the comics right now and this
actually looks like more of the modern
Miles Morales he's aged up a bit uh both
of his parents are still here in the
storyline and it's dealing with him
fighting between school and being
Spider-Man in the current comic books
he's kind of accepted the fact that his
grades cannot be as good and be
Spider-Man but he's still in that school
there's less Genki involved in the
current comic books and that's actually
a point of contention and some of the
villains are are in that school world so
I didn't see Genki in here I'm really
curious if you know there's elements of
his relationship with Gwen that maybe
becomes that sacrifice also seeing
Jessica Drew pregnant uh Jessica Drew as
a mother is one of my favorite comic
runs of all time when she's got a little
baby and she's balancing between being a
parent and and porcupine man is her
babysitter it's a whole thing it's
adorable I love it so much but this to
me is a seemingly Justified rage full
Miguel O'Hara in the comic books Miguel
is one of my favorite characters because
like a tiny example is his claws are
claws to climb with he actually leaves
indentations and buildings there they
protrude and he uses them offensively so
like you can get mauled by Spider-Man 29
like Wolverine he's got literal Talons
on the ends of his fingers he's a more
offensive Spider-Man he's a Spider-Man
that grew up when things were all bad he
grew up in Nuevo York which is a really
rough place so seeing a embittered and
battled emboldened Miguel O'Hara
fighting miles is so special to me
because it seems like they really
captured that feeling while not
sacrificing miles's Journey his story of
sacrifice while not sacrificing his
Heritage one of the things I love about
Miguel is he's half Spanish half Irish
his name is Miguel O'Hara not a lot of
Irish uh Spider-Man in The Journey so
seeing you know all of that mixed with
his character plus there's literally
like Puerto Rican flags in this
background and the snap and these little
moments they're really about the
authenticity of what these characters
mean to the culture they represent not
to mention the different art styles like
spider-gwen's world looking like one
thing in his world looking like another
and I have to say
the Lyle art
l-y-l-e is the artist who designed
Scarlet Spider it's maybe five frames of
this it's like maybe one second half a
second it's less than a second I think
it is exactly Lyle's art and it is the
most 90s thing and it looks like I
couldn't dream of what Scarlet Spider
translated would look like and then they
showed me it the animators just gave me
a thing that I couldn't have thought of
on my own they just hand delivered
something I always wanted that I didn't
know how to quantify that is the most
powerful gift I can even explain how do
you make something in movement you've
always wanted to see and didn't know
even how to describe it and they did it
they did that for me they gave me the
Scarlet Spider of my dreams I love that
character so much I'm gonna do a whole
comic Corner about why I love Scarlet
Spider one day and it's just gonna be
what I think he represents and they
captured it in in like three quarters of
a second for me I'm elated by this
trailer I'm excited to see that
Spider-Man PS4 pops up there when the
point starts and that point joke is
great but it's also going to be very
telling for storytelling I think they're
going to do a really smart thing and
make that element a big shift it's it's
it's so much uh I I can't do 20 minutes
on just this part of the trailers uh but
I am elated to see that it's not
sacrificing Jessica Drew spider Gwen
miles or Miguel for another story it's
not sacrificing what it means to be
Spider-Man which is sacrifice and it's
not sacrificing the first film's Beauty
to continue to escalate and Elevate the
story this looks like a great part one
of two but it also looks like it's gonna
end like Empire and we're gonna need the
Return of the Jedi to bring us forward
and I'm curious if that goes into the
Madame web if that goes into live action
if that brings in elements of other
stories
um because they reference Spider-Man
from our universe and that's also really
messy with continuity it isn't it isn't
Universe 616 616 is the comic books I
don't know why Kevin feige thinks it's
616 he would know but I think he's wrong
I'm with Aman villani and Oscar Isaac as
Spider-Man 2099 here the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is one nine nine nine
nine nine not six one six and it's
referenced here I can't believe it I'm
so excited I cannot wait for this movie
I again could do 20 minutes but I have
to stop so those are the three trailers
um overwhelm is what I feel we're
getting a really fun looking Blue Beetle
I'm not using that derogatory like all
these reviewers seem to do with movies
that are fun we're getting a very
intense grounded and Espionage tastic
secret Invasion which is exactly what it
could be and should be and we're getting
maybe somehow a movie that is even more
advanced and incredible and powerful
than spider-verse in across the spider
verse that trailer that's one of my
favorite trailers of all time I'm I'm
gobsmacked that that first movie came
out of nowhere and changed me and
Spider-Man and this one looks like up
that so let me know in the comments
which one of these is your favorite
trailer let me know if there's anything
I missed let me know if you agree or
disagree about any of the things I had
to say and let me know what else you
want to see from koi's conic corner I am
back home very excited and if you have
any footage for Mega con if you have any
pictures of us from MegaCon you let me
know in the comments it was wonderful to
meet so many of you I can't believe that
across the spider-verse trailer I'm
gonna watch like seven more times that's
what I'm gonna do right now so I'm gonna
say bye so I can watch it again bye all
I love you
foreign